okay Melissa kay asks if you had a
charge enough space fear of water
floating into the space station could a
fish swim in it oh how cool
yes I we've done this with with swedish
fish the candies but special
announcement live
no but theoretically I think that would
work water is uh I mean you could have a
tank of water you have a fish float in
there
I would don't see why we wouldn't be
able to do that and water itself is it
works just on surface tension so it
doesn't splatter so if you were very
creative you could get a glob of water
and try to get a fish they wouldn't even
need a tank no be happy really careful
as soon as it hits something it'll it'll
splatter you don't want to fish nosing
nuzzling his or her way out of the
sphere of water right but I'm pretty
sure there have been experiments with
with fish in space and so yes this is
definitely possible because they'd have
some way to be a nice Christmas gift you
know you have met fabulous zero-g
floating around we have to get pets
flown and this would be a good way so
right now we've had fish as as
experiments this would be like a nice
what animals have been in space I mean
with with astronauts not just like
monkeys that can't make it back or
something right or the dog Laika yeah uh
it's been there's been spiders in space
there have been some rodents in the
house that we use for for experiments
okay so again it's all experiments we
let me ask you this physics question
Mike mass yes the fish are going to
breathe air dissolved in the water when
you have a glob of water in space does
the air bubble its way out effervesce or
does it will it depends it can stay in
there if you have nothing's acting on it
it will it will stay in there in fact
this is a problem with our drink bags
bill when we when we spacewalk because
you don't want air and you drink baggy
clothes no I don't you drink so what we
do is when you fill your drink bag when
you fill a bag of water you drink back
for your spacewalk it's see-through you
can see that there might be air pockets
we rotate the bed we spin it I'm
spinning right now to get the bucket
over your head that's right you spin it
to try to get the air21 to one location
and you suck it out
so you can't get air pockets and you
want those air pockets we'll be right
back and start decorating